what's up guys this idea started at the
office when I was talking about Kanye I
love him and you hate Kanye so we were
like we should do a cancer culture
middle ground yeah we thought it was
really important to bring other topics
like pop culture to middle ground so let
us know in the comments below what you
want us to talk about as always enjoy
the episode r.kelly bye I'm done with
you get out of here like but that's in
your opinion I'm not saying I've got for
our our Kelly I just think if you
support him you're a dick right yeah and
then it's better to be a dick
hello my name is a deep Kadir I have a
computer science degree and I'm a
product manager in the tech industry hi
I'm will Court I'm a music student at
USC hi I'm joy Villa I'm a
singer-songwriter and I am anti cancel
culture hi I'm Lindsay rebelling I'm a
consumer insight specialist and I'm Pro
ich cancel culture more on the site but
I'm looking forward to this conversation
hi I'm Seth Fowler a law school graduate
and teacher I am pro castle culture hi
my name is Alana I am a student a
history student and I'm proconsul
culture I would buy an artist's work
even if they committed a violent crime
humans are a series of impulses on a
spectrum of time like we are constantly
changing we're constantly evolving
have any of you have honestly never not
told a lie in your life of course we
evolved so are you a liar today no so
that moment that you told a lie you
can't be blanketed as a liar the rest of
your life
I think the issue with canceled culture
is it's kind of like this like you have
a cut on your arm let's just chop the
whole arm off when you bring up the
amount of people that work on some of
these projects like think of like a
Harvey Weinstein movie right he did
terrible things I wouldn't want to port
support Harvey Weinstein but most of his
victims are people that were in his
movies by not supporting a Harvey
Weinstein movie are also not supporting
his victims so it's kind of like you're
in a weird spot but you can't bring down
the kingpin without bringing down the
organization that he built so he said
something very interesting to me about
like the whole cutting off the arm and
to fix a cut and I feel like the exact
opposite because when you talk about how
like oh if you're canceling people bond
they have good inventions it's like
there's so many smart people that aren't
toxic and it's like when you cancel
someone that is toxic it's sending the
message to other toxic people you cannot
get away with this here's how I think of
it like I have the right to stop this
and if other people want to do that also
and we bond together
like the powers in our hands and I feel
like for me I'm doing my part by not
choosing on to like mess with that
person anymore yeah I was gonna ask you
a question though do you feel like you
should be the one making the decision or
do you feel like YouTube or Spotify
should make the decision for you and
take down people who they feel like
offended a certain segment of the
population I think it's it's it's two
separate things like I think I should
have the power to make that decision of
course that's a very personal thing for
me but music should be continued to be
sold and available I personally don't
think so just don't listen to don't buy
it you yourself yeah absolutely every
individual has the right to say hey I
don't like this and you can even tweet
about and saying no but then to start a
boycott that's what yeah boycott people
are different morally I personally have
the right
I withhold the right I think all of us
do to not go and support these people we
don't believe in I would never tell you
wait I'm gonna go see X Y Z movie and
you have to - if you say no you have
that right what cancel culture does is
saying I'm not gonna see this person
because I don't like this person and
nobody else should either and that's why
I hate it
cancel culture is out of control
when it started I think it was a good
thing it's like the me to movement a
good thing but when you get the court of
public opinion involved I tell you it
becomes so horrible I am an artist I've
legitimately hit number one on Billboard
people think oh I don't run my social
media I absolutely do I read comments I
respond even negative ones when people
say I hope you die
somebody should kill your family you
should get raped so that you you have a
baby a legit mean you can I mean it is
online bullying cancel culture
rationally is overall a net positive I
think but there are sects of cancel
culture like the toxic people that issue
the death threats and of course those
need to be excised cancel culture
originated out of compassion the voice
for the voiceless being able to vote
with your wallet make a stand yeah your
little retweet your little like turning
things viral that one gets seen this is
something that like strikes fear in my
heart right now what's happening now is
you know people are essentially choosing
for you whether you should be it's like
it's like let's say you wanted to
boycott coca-cola or Nike or something
imagine if stores started taking Nike
shoes out of the store before you could
even make the decision as a people to
buy it or not buy it and we need to have
the right and in the option at our love
I don't think that they're trying to
make you not buy the product I think
that they're saying as a company we do
not agree with this so we're not gonna
sell your product here when record
labels stop playing their music or
whatever I feel like it's justified
specifically for victims because when it
gets out that that person did something
like that their music skyrockets and for
the victim seeing that they're getting
so much for that and then once the cases
are over it's been sure you could play
their music more if they are innocent
but it's also like the justice system
isn't always right
honestly I've said this before like I
think the pendulum has swung the other
direction and like
yes maybe it's getting a little string
but I also think sometimes that's
necessary for a change
for so long we let everyone get away
with everything and there was only one
voice as part of the conversation right
it was mostly like white men back in the
day versus now we have a platform where
everyone can share their opinion you're
like hey that makes me uncomfortable and
I think some people are going to have to
be made examples of in order to set
precedent and what's acceptable for us
our generation and the society today
the public should hold celebrities
accountable when the justice system
fails our Kelly is the first name that
comes to mind because he has sex tapes
that show his face and people are still
like didn't do it
we love our Kelly he would never and
most of the time when it's a celebrity
being convicted they can always buy
their way out that's exactly we came to
mind for me too
immediately I was just like oh like
first of all how many times how many
times in like the United States justice
system have we seen guilty people get
off innocent and you find off years
later that that happened if the justice
system doesn't come through we as a
people shouldn't just take that and be
like okay well I guess he's innocent
like no he did that and let's take away
his platform and we will take that power
away from him the justice system is so
it's just so imperfect it's unbelievable
and I think that situations like Jesse
Smollett
I think that the justice system in those
situations have failed if we don't
support the justice system a little bit
then it's kind of anarchy but at the
same time I think that it's an
individual decision as the individual as
the right to kind of I don't not not
support them or you know to do whatever
they want to do ya know extreme extreme
if the justice system fails what's
important and what's happening now is
that we do look at replacing whether
it's the district attorney or whatever
the system is that's causing it to fail
people should go and address this so the
next million
people that go through that system go
through a just system I think we all
completely agree with that like the
justice system needs to be fixed but I
do think the reason canceled culture
started and when it originally derived
was because like to be 100 I like that
takes so long like for our entire
government and justice system to like
evolve until you're idealistic view of
it is not happening next year where I
think we're making change I think it's
happening but I think our generation
that spawned canceled culture was like
you don't have time we have the same
problems with canceled cultures we do
with the justice system there's a lot of
people that got they got the death
penalty right we're giving people the
their careers of the death penalty by
public you know and kicking them out
forever and saying we never want you
back right are we because I've canceled
the NFL since but what if we're wrong
it was a countable culture I'd be on
that side cancel when I cancel you you
don't exist delete it by get out of here
no more money we're done with them
cancels this imperfect as the justices
are Kelly by I'm done with you get out
of here like but that's in your opinion
I'm not saying I'm before Kelly but I
still don't want all his music erased
like all of a sudden it's like he's
guilty before a court of law
even people I don't support I still want
them to go to the justice system because
fairness matters we've already been
through this throughout history I just
think if you support him you're a dick
right yeah and it's all right to hate
them counsel culture it runs I would say
codependent ly with activism and as
activism has changed we're able to
operate quicker and mobilize quicker in
this digital space it's almost in some
senses it's like digital activism but I
like compassionate canceller culture if
you look at the history of somebody and
you look at how somebody responds when
confronted and you make your decision
based off of whether they've seen any
type of error and applied any type of
value judgment then I think it's totally
your right whether or not to support
them we have too many options
yeah and I love that you said it's your
right I just think what's most important
about anything is that if you're going
to stop listening to someone stop
supporting someone you know do your
research and make it make the moral
decision for yourself of whether you
want to support them or not and that's
that's all you can do as an individual
it's an individual decision we all kind
of have the same opinion on a level for
the most part we think that people
deserve consequences but I feel like we
think it good I thank you guys so much
for watching this episode a lot of times
middle ground is very tense but we love
bringing people together to have healthy
dialogue nonetheless yeah now so we're
very active on social media so make sure
to follow us on Instagram and do blue
media we're also thinking of completely
revamping the ground so you've got cool
ideas of like what we can do next or
like anything like that leave a comment
DM us as always we'll see you guys next
time